Hey there, I'm Tiffany Smith for Fandango Movieclips
and I'm super excited
because London Has Fallen is coming to theaters
and it is the follow up,
No, not to White House Down
This is the follow up to Olympus Has Fallen.
In honor of the Fall of London,
we thought we would put together the most cinematic ways to destroy a city.
And of course we've got, Mother Nature herself.
That's right, we're talking about a good, old-fashioned natural disaster.
There's nothing quite like a volcano in a populated metropolitan area like Los Angeles.
which, I gotta say is a nice change of pace from their usual earthquakes,
and speaking of earthquakes, they can prove to really shake things up and knock 'em down.
Well, unless you've got you know, Dwayne Johnson just hanging out
'cuz he always saves the day.
Next up are our friends in the animal kingdom.
I gotta say you guys,  the way that we treat them,
I feel like we're kind of asking for it.
So the next time you come across a giant ape, in the wild,
or discover a way to bring back an extinct species,
think twice, before you do something that might really tick off a giant lizard,
or a stampeding rhinoceros,
Moving along to my personal favorite, the ironic superhero fight.
Yes, they're just trying to save the city,
but with all those powerful punches, flying bodies, and lazer blasts,
there's bound to be some collateral damage,
a pretty hefty price tag, and don't get me started on the traffic.
But I still love superheroes!
And next on the list, we need to look to the stars.
That's right, I'm talking about aliens
and not the cute, candy eating kind that just wanna touch your finger and phone home.
I'm talking about the face-melting, earth-harvesting, lazer-blasting from their eyes, terrifying aliens.
Whether they attack from the skies, or in their badass spaceships,
or, they come through a portal on the ocean floor, they mean, business.
And they don't have much respect for our people, our cities, or even our really cool landmarks.
Alright, so that brings us to basic human stupidity.
That's right, our methods may be a little bit more subtle, but at the end of the day,
we are just as capable of destroying our own cities and planets as any cold-blooded alien.
I'm Tiffany Smith for Fandango Movieclips, thanks for watching!